[Musik]
parkhaus urania in zürich 1991
mitten am nachmittag wird eine junge
frau niedergestochen
das opfer stirbt am tatort
die polizei sucht nach einem brutalen
mörder ein fataler irrtum dass es
übliche serientäterin geht gefährliche
das hat mir bis anhin dankbarkeit bei
uns im judo serviert wird das auch nicht
das motiv der täterin sauber zeit noch
lust am töten sie
[Musik]
1991 an einem warmen junitag zieht es
die innerschweizerin caroline h nach
zürich ins parkhaus urania
nicht zum ersten mal mit dem lift fährt
die 18 jährige rauf und runter wie immer
trägt sie ein messer auf sich
[Musik]
sie hält ausschau nach einem opfer sie
will endlich ihre fantasie eine frau
umzubringen in die tat umsetzen
im siebten stock des damals düsteren
parkhauses vernimmt sie das klappern von
absetzen alles geht blitzschnell
[Musik]
sie hat sich ihre vorhin geknechtet die
frauen hat sich weil ein unternehmen die
steine auf sie und sie hätten mit einer
sogenannten beta von einem meister
wieder in den rücken gestochen und das
hätten auch sofort zur öffentlich von
der schlag oder im innenbereich geführt
und die freiheit vorteile
verletzlichkeit um das überleben nach
der tat verlässt carolina das parkhaus
unbemerkt bei späteren einvernahmen
beschreibt sie das geschehene nüchtern
ich habe die frau überrascht wir standen
uns einen sehr kurzen moment gegenüber
sie hat er gar nicht realisiert was da
vor sich geht sie hatte auch nicht groß
geschrieben
die frau die im parkhaus urania getötet
wurde ist eine 29 jährige aargauerin im
kofferraum ihres autos findet die
polizei ein festkleid sie hätte es an
der bevorstehenden hochzeit der
schwester getragen
bald hätte sie auch ihre eigene hochzeit
gefeiert
nach der bluttat steht die polizei vor
einem rätsel mehrheit die richtige
recherchierte wissenschaftlich die ente
stellt detektiv aufbruch der mehrheit
fand ichs bilder gemacht mehrheit um
früher für die bevölkerung machten das
auch liebevoll gemacht man wirklich
alles erdenkliche gemacht und trotzdem
sie mit an und für sich kämpfen
die polizei fahndet nach einem oder zwei
männern
die öffentlichkeit ist alarmiert schnell
bekommt der fall eine politische
dimension frauen fordern sichere
parkplätze für den strafrechts professor
der universität zürich christian
schwarzenegger ist klar dass polizei und
öffentlichkeit von einem männlichen
täter ausgehen der qualität da ist
einmal vor dem könnt alle usa sowie der
polizei der justiz gesellschaft und das
hat jedem fall die untersuchung einer
völlig falsche richtig gelangt
es hat sogar dazu geführt dass man
parkhäuser frauenparkplatz separat
abgesondert hat man größere beleg führt
will man eben immer die gefahr wie man
ein männlicher täter verankert hat
weil eine frau als täterin undenkbar ist
bleibt caroline h unbehelligt wenige
tage nach dem mord im parkhaus beginnt
sie eine verkaufs lehre in luzern
die bricht sie wie alle folgenden nach
kurzer zeit ab
[Musik]
in dieser zeit 1991 92 geht ein
feuerteufel um in luzern
die brandserie beginnt mit kleinen
sachbeschädigungen später lodern
schuppen dann bewohnte häuser
spektakulär ist der großbrand eines
holzlagers einer schreinerei die
feuerwehr steht im großeinsatz
trotzdem kommt es zum totalschaden
niemand ahnt dass die parkhausmörderin
und die serien brandstifterin dieselbe
junge frau sind den höhepunkt der
brandserie kündigt sie im april 1992 an
seit dem mord im parkhaus ist ein
knappes jahr vergangen
auf einer zugtoilette beschreibt sie
eine papierserviette ich bin ein
brandstifter heute nacht gibt es den
zweiten großbrand in luzern
ich kann es nicht lassen die serviette
lässt sie liegen
320 studierten ist ein paar bier
serviert man trug zum teil dort rechnen
die toilette wo man nicht so oft vor und
wurde von einer passantin die teure
diese werte der begrenzung für den brand
wurden und nun dränge mich kann es nicht
lassen und am juni 20 stellen versucht
ganze den wirklich um commander gebäude
da die täterarbeit der brandauer und
taktisch gelöscht und dann ist dieser
vorgang jetzt dpa schachteln ac n t
projekte und den dachstock brand
ausgelöst
der brauch ist so intensiv und mit
wassermeister die kämpfe seien dort
außerdem gebäude greift am historischen
gebäude entsteht ein schaden in
millionenhöhe
die kriminalpolizei luzern geht von
einem brandstifter aus von einem mann
[Musik]
für carolin h ist davon muss großbrand
ein erfolg sie ist stolz darauf und
macht andeutungen gegenüber einer
bekannten das wird ihr zum verhängnis
er gibt der polizei den entscheidenden
hinweis
wenige tage später kommt caroline h in
luzern in untersuchungshaft
sie gesteht 40 brandstiftungen auch
menschenleben hat sie gefährdet
der gesamtschaden beträgt 4,5 millionen
franken
carolin häußler so dass sie sich
natürlich mit einer brandstiftung große
aktion verursacht sie hat für das bleibt
vor dem bleibt dass sie die daten an
einzelheiten könne schon wieder der
laterne
sie hat sich so schneller factor etwas
wie der lack können konsumieren quasi
und das der musik hat sie zum teil der
brand einer garage steht morgen und
herzlich
trotzdem muss sich ausgelöste als serien
brandstifterin findet carolina
aufmerksamkeit und beachtung noch lange
ahnt niemand dass die 19 jährige ein
knappes jahr zuvor eine frau getötet hat
[Musik]
kriminelle karriere machen sie ja schon
früher bemerkbar das ist nicht unbedingt
show kriminelles verhalten
das sind fantasie richtig quelle
reagiert oder wo man so spielt wie immer
über tötet jetzt in dem konkreten fall
ist das eine schon sehr früh gesprochen
habe ich mich auch seine ist es zu der
stiko aber die die widrige die verlauf
zeigt dass das eigentlich so typisch ist
für die quirligkeit nämlich dass man
ganz verschiedene delikte geht und dass
man das dass sich das verhalten immer
mehr verstärkt
aufgewachsen ist caroline h in der
innerschweiz in einem ländlichen 4000
seelen dorf hier geht sie zur schule
ihre eltern sind gebürtige österreicher
sie leben seit jahrzehnten im dorf und
sind gut integriert
ihre kindheit sei intakt gewesen sagen
psychiater später im dorf erinnert man
sich ihre als scheues mädchen mit
blondem haar meist auf 40 sachen und ist
ganz ehrlich nur schlanke maltritz r
nacht
während der realschule sondert sich
caroline h immer mehr ab gleichzeitig
habe sie darunter gelitten dass sie
wenig beachtet worden sei sagt sie
später
sie begeht kleinere delikte auch
brandstiftungen in der umgebung die in
holz schober in flammen auf fotograf
josef reinhardt hat sein leben lang
unfälle und brände dokumentiert
katastrophen selbst nennen ihn die leute
er ist caroline h unmittelbar nach einer
brandstiftung begegnet
ja ich konnte schon kann und für sich
und das sogar ganz aus der das auch zu
uns
carolin haar fällt negativ auf mehrmals
bricht sie lehrstellen ab sie ist
gekränkt äußert drohungen
man munkelt sie habe psychische probleme
die einbürgerung wird ihr verweigert ihr
traum polizistin zu werden platzt zurück
nach luzern 1992 kommt caroline h in
untersuchungshaft
sie gesteht 40 brandstiftungen
[Applaus]
es folgt der prozess vor dem luzerner
kriminalgericht niemand etwas vom
parkhaus mord vor zwei jahren bezüglich
der brandstiftungen zeigt caroline h
weder einsicht noch reue eine
menschenverachtende art kam tätigung von
faktoren
das gericht folgt der staatsanwältin und
verurteilte die 20 jährige caroline h zu
vier jahren zuchthaus
darüber hinaus ordnete die verwahrung an
das heißt hinter gittern auf unbestimmte
zeit
die verwahrung einer 20-jährigen frau
ist damals sehr umstritten insbesondere
in bezug auf eine frau insbesondere in
bezug auf die carolina wo eigentlich so
aus ganz viel liebster stehen die damals
und mir eigentlich
kunst im gefängnis fällt caroline h
durch renitentes verhalten auf trotzdem
hebt das obergericht luzern als zweiter
instanz die verwahrung auf und senkt die
strafe um ein halbes jahr auf
dreieinhalb jahre
ausschlaggebend sind neue positive
psychiatrische gutachten auf diese neuen
befunde stützt sich das mildere urteil
des obergerichts ein brisanter entscheid
schaut man den weiteren werdegang
carolin haas damals und eben noch werde
ich meine premiere mit einer frau eine
gewaltbereitschaft und anfangs der 90er
jahre waren psychiatrische gutachten
nicht standardisiert bis heute gibt es
bei uns nur wenige forensische
psychiater die von der fachgesellschaft
zertifiziert sind gutachten über
straftäter anzufertigen sieht die
problematik von gefährlicher täter im
vordergrund steht probiert der
qualitätssteigerung von einem gutachter
man hat auch verbessere fachausbildung
und probiert auch die methode
statistisch genauer zu machen
aber man darf natürlich nicht vergessen
dass in zukunft zu sagen eine
gemeinschafts verhalten und die sind
immer ungenau und bis jetzt hat man da
eigentlich nur der so einen standard
erreicht dass manche user kann ich keine
aussage
[Musik]
1996 kommt caroline h nach zürich ihre
strafe von dreieinhalb jahren hat sie im
gefängnis verbüßt die 23-jährige macht
kampfsport
wieder fängt sie eine lehre an diesmal
als elektrikerin widerlegt sie brände
und gefährdet menschenleben
[Musik]
wieder zieht es sie in parkhäuser
wieder hat sie den film im kopf eine
frau erschrecken und töten wie damals
vor fünf jahren
[Musik]
im parkhaus hohe promenade lauert sie
einer frau auf wenige meter vor carolin
h kehrt diese unvermittelt um und fährt
mit dem auto davon
für carolin h ein misserfolg wie sie in
einer späteren einvernahme schildert
ich kam gar nicht dazu zu versuchen sie
zu töten
sie lief davon nach rhenen mochte ich
hier eigentlich nicht ich hätte versucht
die frau zu erstechen
es hat mich einfach gereizt es nochmals
zu machen
ich hatte lust es nochmals zu machen
der trieb zu töten die lust am morden
andreas frey ist forensischer psychiater
er hat caroline h über längere zeit
begutachtet und mordlust diagnostiziert
das ist eins davon ist ishii
kinoregisseur darum des mordens wähle
tötet und dann wird man autos sagen und
das ist dank ich bitte karin h nach
alves ihre daten so schildert eva lux
bei frauen ist mordlust noch seltener
als bei männern
aber schon bald wird diese bei carolina
wieder übermächtig im januar 1997 geht
sie gegen 19 uhr zur zürcher
seepromenade wieder hält sie ausschau
nach einer frau wieder sucht sie ein
opfer nach einer halben stunde will sie
aufgeben
dann sieht carolina eine spaziergängerin
eine 61-jährige frau
[Applaus]
caroline h nähert sich ihr legt ihr den
arm um den hals und sticht mit dem
teppichmesser zu die frau groß und stark
leistet heftige gegenwehr
die klinge des teppichmesser bricht ab
caroline h nimmt ein klappmesser zur
hand
erneut sticht sie wie von sinnen auf das
opfer ein
[Musik]
dann geht sie zum see um hände und
messer vom blut zu reinigen
sie packt einen stein geht zurück zum
opfer und schlägt ihm damit mehrmals auf
den kopf
[Musik]
das ist einfacher ähnlich wie im urania
parkhaus fall politisch an und für sich
vorher bereits gestanden es hat nicht
wirklich als motiv gab jährigen
abflugzeit kbc xd liegt die raum ob sie
ein raucher weekend rennen ausschlüsse
und aufgrund verteilen ist man natürlich
immer wieder den punkt warum gerade das
muss irgendein x oder mehrere täter sie
am folgenden tag findet die polizei bei
der leiche spuren des erbitterten kampf
das teppichmesser den blutverschmierten
stein den abgerissen und knopf von
mantel des opfers der mantel ist mit
messerstichen übersät
[Musik]
30 mal hat caroline h zugestochen
bei der späteren einvernahme gesteht
caroline h dass sie mit der tat beim
chinagarten nicht zufrieden war sie die
perfektionistin hatte im kopf ein
anderes drehbuch
es hätte aber schneller gehen müssen
sie hatte schneller angst haben und
schneller tot sein müssen
ich konnte nicht mehr aufhören wenn ich
einmal in fahrt bin dann kann mich
nichts mehr stoppen
mit 24 jahren hat caroline h bereits
zwei menschen umgebracht
generell aber gibt es nur ganz wenige
frauen die töten frauen sind
grundsätzlich weniger kriminell
auseinander und bittet kriminalität sind
es zehn prozent überhaupt und sie sind
in eine andere rolle tätig teilweise als
mit trainer teil des bezirks konfliktes
entsteht das also es ist wenn man so
will chronologisch gesehen nicht so
schwerwiegend wie die ähnliche tricks
kriminalität und auf der andere sieht
ist es dann wenn es um das qualität hat
mir der schweiz momentan um erfahrungen
sind vier frauen wo aufgrund von ihrer
gefährlichkeit verwahrt sind
ein jahr später 1998 schlägt carolina
erneut zu in einer buchhandlung in
zürichs altstadt an einem samstagmorgen
um 11 uhr betritt sie das geschäft die
junge frau stellt sich ja dass die 75
jährige buchhändlerin allein im geschäft
ist dann sticht sie zwölf mal zu wieder
richtet sie ein blutbad an
die buchhändlerin wird lebensgefährlich
verletzt caroline h stellt sich auf das
opfer um es ganz bewegungsunfähig zu
machen
aus der ladenkasse steht sie 400 franken
unerkannt verlässt sie den tatort
oberhalb der buchhandlung wohnt damals
ein arzt ihr rettet der frau das leben
bietet die burg handliche und burhan
schräg funde am boden liegend doch ich
hatte schon ein ausbrechen
ich habe kapiert michlits orientiere
auch probiert weiter zu öffnen wir nie
druck zu machen ohne bedacht vor der
verletzung sek dass sie diverse
stichwunden am hals
manche märkte zu beruhigen dass im
moment ein kämpferisch kann sie dann
glaube ich immer aus wie manch einer
sagt was lauf dass man dass die probleme
jetzt ein schnelles später aufbringen
die angst geht um im quartier denn das
opfer vom chinagarten wohnte nur zwei
häuser neben der buchhandlung man
vermutet einen zusammenhang zwischen den
beiden bluttaten speziell wegen der im
visier
und das ist ausgewogen sie ist wäre ich
den akt aber opfer gibt es keine
weiteren die buchhändlerin überlebt es
sollte sich herausstellen dass der
gemeinsame wohnort zufall war
kein zufall ist dass alle drei opfer
frauen sind caroline h lehnt alles
weibliche ab frauen sind für sie
verachtenswert abscheulich und muss alle
dass das forum von supplementen selbst
ausgesät
immer mehr machen caroline h ihre taten
zu schaffen
sie weist sich selber in eine
psychiatrische klinik ein
gegenüber betreuern erwähnt sie träume
in denen sie frauen tötet die polizei
wird eingeschaltet
langwierige einvernahmen beginnen dürfen
ist klar dass sich weil eine richterin
und damals auch immer verträumt erzählt
sie hat an und will sich nun auf und
zwar gerne gesagt sehr gelassen und das
gemacht der detektiv hat dann aber ganz
klar keine verbindung zur parks
chinagarten hersteller wo ihm bewusst
sie sind das dementi selektiv wir hatten
natürlich auswärtige vor der recherche
für die polizei bezogen und das hat sich
zeigt dass die caroline h details
erzählt hat wo an und für sich nur um
täter oder die täterin bekannt sind
konfrontiert sie die polizei jedoch zu
direkt mit den taten verliert sie
unvermittelt die kontrolle der vorherige
wie die polizei innerhalb von sekunden
explodiert ist dass sie einmal eine
polizeistreife brauche
dafür musste ich einfach vorstellen dass
ich wirklich explosiv und der andere
sieht die absolute teilnahmslos mit
einer übernahme
auch die kantonspolizei luzern verhört
caroline h noch einmal wegen ungeklärten
brandstiftungen
auch hier gilt sie als hochrisiko
gefangenen die energie gar nicht was du
dir keine wahnsinnige ständig schauen
kriege unterwegs und die kleine videos
eine explodiert und dann sehen es auch
unter anderem sollen sie explodiert sind
drei semester wird gerade unten im büro
und das eigentlich schon das
aggressionspotenzial wo die frau geht
also dass sie wertvoll ist sehr fröhlich
geschätzt ein quasi zum das auch macht
es ist eine frau und wir sind sollten
die kajüte konfrontiert der zwischenfall
bleibt nicht folgenlos
die kantonspolizei luzern baut im
einvernahme zimmer eine zelle ein
in der aggressive untersuchungshäftlinge
während der befragung eingeschlossen
werden können
nach monatelangen heiklen einvernahmen
ist caroline h in zürich vollumfänglich
geständig
1999 acht jahre nach der bluttat im
urania parkhaus wird es jetzt öffentlich
der mörder ist eine frau
caroline h
zwei jahre später am 17 dezember 2001
kommt es zum indizienprozess am
obergericht zürich
das öffentliche interesse ist riesig
jörg fans war damals staatsanwalt seine
anklage basierte fast ausschließlich auf
geständnissen der täterin darin konkret
der faulheit täterin caroline h jeweils
ganz detailliert die user gemacht
bezüglich der einzelne taten
aus sorge und details wo wirklich nur
der täter müsse der hypnose devise
wieder das bespiel vereine im urania
tötungsdelikt dark side im moment sie
aber gestocher heute handke und sie sich
mit auffallenden schuhe mit hohen absatz
begleitet sie und die schuhe der bundes
grüße stuck tack tack verursachen dass
sie gegen auffangen so bissig wie der
media hub zwei prozesstage lang setzt
caroline h hier im saal
neben ihr ein sicherheitsbeamter des
frauengefängnisses hindelbank auf
eigenen wunsch trägt sie hand- und
fussfesseln ohne fühle sie sich nackt
sagt sie mit leiser stimme schildert sie
noch einmal ihre taten erzählt vom
geräusch der absätze dass sie genervt
habe erzählt dass sie frauen verachte
weil sie schwach sein
carolin haar wirkt angespannt und doch
unbeteiligt vor gericht bescheinigt
psychiater andreas frey der 28-jährigen
serientäterin eine hohe gefährlichkeit
und empfiehlt die verwahrung damals eine
kombinierte persönlichkeitsstörung redet
sehr komplex sie sich dass wir haben
damals von sie zu jeder narzisstische
und borderline persönlichkeitsstörung
redet wohl wissend dass die kategorie zu
verfügen kann manchmal nur sehr ungenau
phänomen beschrieben heißt sonderbar
schloss rassistisch ist malerisch
grandios und borderline heißt emotional
instabil also wachsende kühl und plane
eine sitz- und wofür jubeln anders als
sicherheit für die persönlichkeit kann
man eigentlich sagen
am prozess zeigt caroline h keine
emotionen
weder mitleid mit den opfern noch reue
sie sagt man solle die gesellschaft vor
ihr schützen
das obergericht spricht caroline h
schuldig
des mordes im urania parkhaus
[Musik]
des mordes beim china garten des
versuchten mordes an der buchhändlerin
der 50-fachen brandstiftung sowie
weiterer delikte
der schuldspruch lautet lebenslange
zuchthausstrafe und verwahrung auf
unbestimmte zeit
es ist die höchststrafe urteil wenig
seelische ob sie in dem verfahren
der ganze prozess kommt von einer tat
öffentlichkeit in zukunft vor der
beitritt schützen und mittel dazu
strafrecht vor traurig und ich habe die
eba tried und gerichtet aufgrund der
situation richtig entschieden und hätten
eine verwahrung auf unbestimmte zeit
ausgesprochen
anders der verteidiger nach der
gerichtsverhandlung kritisiert er das
urteil als übersteigerten
sicherheitsfirmen
ich hoffe sie dass er so eine verwahrung
und absolute sicherheit sowie das der
referent quadrat hat das niemanden
entlassen werden weil sie absolut die
sicherheit ich das nicht passiert so
eine absolute sicherheit gibt sagte
kammann
caroline h wird abgeführt
sie kommt in die frauen vollzugsanstalt
hindelbank hier ist sie nicht den
normalen vollzug im hochsicherheitstrakt
wo sie einsetzt dürfen wir nicht filmen
aus sicherheitsgründen
weil caroline h als gemeingefährliche
täterin gilt ist sie in einzelhaft
das heißt keine sozialen kontakte und
unter ständiger überwachung
[Musik]
die verwahrte hat keine aussicht auf
entlassung ihr leben spielt sich
zwischen arbeits und wohnzimmer ab ihre
zelle misst 16 quadratmeter eine normale
zelle ist zwölf quadratmeter groß
[Musik]
auch für terroristen als und handlung
kann man merkt es gibt sehr allein ist
wahrscheinlich länger als andere
sie haben sich letzte zug aus wo sie
nachts individuelle dichte weil sie aus
der musik auch zum schafe getötet oder
schafe auf als dass man sich jetzt ist
oder zu nachhaltigen arbeitszeit im
sommer 14 47 hoch
täglich kann sie eine stunde trainieren
drinnen oder draußen auf dem hof
dieser ist mit einem erdwall umgeben
retourniert und vergittert 4 x 4 meter
wie ihre zelle anwalt mathias brunner
vertritt caroline h seit fünf jahren er
ist überzeugt dass die isolierung
zermürbend wird gespürt dass das kind
krank ist eine besondere häftlingen
anregungen
die nahmen teil am klang ist aber das
ist studierter soziologe
er hat kontakt hat bessere schlechtere
aktivitäten gemeinsam schaffen und sich
alles gefallen und sie merken natürlich
dass das ihr job gemacht dass das nicht
zu den wenigen außen kontakten gehören
die eltern sie besuchen caroline h
regelmäßig über fehlende beziehungen
können tiere hinweghelfen
in hindelbank spielen sie eine wichtige
rolle
caroline h hat seit sieben jahren eine
katze namens zeus
sie kann sich frei bewegen und gibt ihr
halt so lasst unser stadtbewohnern und
home ist etwas was genau das leben ist
genau gezählt hatte mit zählt auch die
bezugsmöglichkeit ist diese situation
hat sich unabhängigen ganzen also machen
der zustand von carolin h s labil es
gibt phasen in denen sie ihre taten
leugnete
chancen auf eine intensive therapie hat
sie momentan keine mangels
erfolgsaussichten
der blick nach vorn ist schwierig sagt
nick carter auch nicht kein
auskömmliches motor andere werden es
auch um kracht ein händler
das ist respektlos situation vom
innenhof lebens davon machen also heute
keine perspektive bezeichnet
aber machen das gegenteil der macht und
sagt es ist schlicht und einfach im
moment und damit mir die entwicklung zu
erwarten sind peter frau habe nur brot
ist es sehr wichtig dass sie in den
kommenden jahren strafvollzug werde und
es mit und lebensqualität und lars
vielleicht verliert mit einer täterin
wie caroline h hat niemand gerechnet
weder die polizei noch die justiz
sie wird wohl immer eine ausnahme
bleiben
eigentlich unfassbar
[Musik]